una espiral inflacionaria por culpa de
la pandemia el impacto del joven 19 en
la economía del 2021 afectó sobre todo
la cadena de suministros globales esto
se tradujo en una dificultad para
satisfacer la demanda internacional es
un escenario que ha generado un alza en
la inflación de varios países por
ejemplo en perú la tasa anual del 2021
fue del 6,43 por ciento una cifra
impulsada sobre todo por un repunte de
más del 13% en vivienda combustibles y
electricidad y de cerca del 8% en
alimentos y bebidas para colombia las
autoridades monetarias auguran una
inflación superior al 5 por ciento en el
año que terminó muy por encima de la
meta brasil preocupa un índice de
precios que ya es de 2 dígitos aquí se
debe este fenómeno de generar en américa
latina hay tres factores fundamentales
un factor que sería el peso del petróleo
que fue aumentando en forma sideral otro
elemento importante es el aumento del
dólar el dólar como moneda de refugio y
también en algunos países américa
latinael incertidumbre política
eeuu no está al margen el gobierno
reportó que los precios en noviembre
subieron un 6 8% en un año la inflación
más alta en 39 años lo que eleva la
presión sobre las tasas de interés de la
reserva federal y entendemos que una
alta inflación supone un obstáculo
importante especialmente sobre aquellos
con menor capacidad para hacer frente a
los costos más altos de los bienes
esenciales para el 2022 se espera una
merma en estos índices de precios de la
mano en parte de una reducción en la
cotización del petróleo pero la
incertidumbre viene de cómo se comporte
la economía china un aliado crucial para
varios países de américa latina'